it's the nightmare scenario amazon might
be planning a hard reboot of stargate
welcome to scitrek your sci-fi tv and
movie channel
we all know we live in a reboot society
but there's options for any tv
executives or movie executives when
planning a reboot you can either do um a
continuation of a story but years down
the line with new characters you can do
what they call a soft reboot where you
have completely new characters a
completely new story but the universe
stays the same
you live within the same universe the
same rules apply the old tv show still
happened
or you can do a hard reboot new actors
new story you pretend like the old show
never even happened now i've done a lot
of videos recently about stargate and i
have a contact and a couple of contacts
now within mgm that have been feeding me
little bits of information and this has
come from them please check the card out
you can go to the playlist and go
through all the videos it tells you
everything you need to know
but what have i been told so
back in 2016
dean devlin and roland denmark actually
pitched to mgm and mgm had a deal with
warner brothers temporarily um to do a
stargate sequel now this was along the
lines of actually a plan they had back
in 1994 the original star gate movie
with kurt russell and james spader was
supposed to be a trilogy there was
supposed to be three movies the first
movie was supposed to be based on the
egyptian mythology which obviously we
saw
the next movie which i'm going to tell
you a little bit about another video
because i know the working title
and i know a way we can get around this
whole reboot thing as well um so please
like subscribe hit that bell
notification to catch that video when it
comes out
and we're supposed to be around a
different mythology
um and then a third movie that was
supposed to bring it all together
now
in 2016 mgm's
plan
for the trilogy was around the same idea
they had back in 1994 so the sequel is
going to be this movie that the working
title was first gods
this was planned and apparently kurt
russell and james spader were interested
in coming back
jonathan gluckman was the mgm um chief
executive at the time and he actually
said the only way we're going to inject
some adrenaline back into this show was
is if we bring back
ronald emmerich and dean devlin it's the
only way to get this franchise up and
running again
steve devlin was quoted as saying that
the only way after 20 years to do this
movie now is to do a complete reboot so
it seems that ronald emmerich and dean
devlin
and mgm at the time luckily jonathan
lookman isn't the chief executive of mgm
anymore
wanted to do a hard reboot but more than
that they believed it was the only way
to do it because too much time had
passed
but
sg-1 came along now at the time
um
brad wright jonathan glasner and robert
c cooper actually did get a handout and
did want to speak to dean devlin and
roland emmerich about their plans for
sg1 they wanted to get their input on
the new tv series before sg-1 started
ronald emmerich and dean devlin refused
that
hand
they didn't want to talk about it they
didn't like the idea of it being a tv
series and they were still annoyed
back in 1996 when this conversation
happened about the tv series happening
at all
so there's no love lost between these
two projects now according to my sources
amazon
as soon as they came in saw what mgm was
planning for the new series led by brad
wright
and they felt that it needed to be
bigger a lot grander now that made me
concerned immediately because what is
that because what does that mean
well
it seems to me that it means that
they're going to bring back and this is
what i've been told this plan for the
trilogy this will be big movie stars
this will be a big budget movie on
trilogy and movies now that's exciting
and also apparently there has already
been a conversation apparently a zoom
call
during a series of meetings that
happened at the end of october early
november between amazon and mgm
executives
a zoom call happened with roland
emmerich
this zoom call was a brief pitch meeting
about the notes that he prepared back in
2016 and
how he felt they could be moved on now
so apparently
amazon has dusted off these plans and
they think seem to think it's the way to
go
the thing that worries me about this
rumor and it is a rumor um i can't
confirm it as well as i've been able to
confirm other things which is why i've
taken a little bit of time to get this
video out even though i was told this
nearly a month ago um
is because
it kind of fits with everything else
i've been told i voted in another video
please go back and check the playlist
about how amazon seemed to be trying to
freeze brad right out
and brad wright to be fair to him is
pushing back
that would make sense to me
if they're planning a complete hard
reboot because we know from what brad
wright said that that's not what he
wants he does not want a hard reboot he
wants a continuation of the story new
characters he wants a soft reboot if
anything
the old universe happened we're gonna
have new characters and maybe try to
bring in a few new characters amanda
tapping and michael shanks at top of
that list
if amazon are going to do full reboot
they're going to go with completely new
creators brad wright won't be involved
and i don't think brad white would want
to be involved if 100 honest
but roland emmerich would be interested
what do i think
i think amazon are planning a full
reboot
i think um mgm we're going to do brad
wright's vision kovid stop that
and then obviously the sale went through
and amazon basically put the brakes on
any new stargate project i think if the
new roller denrick 2022 movie moonfall
is even remotely successful i mean it
does look good i'm loving what i see of
it and that i think roland denmark will
sign on to do a stargate trilogy quite
quickly um
middle of next year towards the end of
next year
um
i think
i'm actually very worried that this
story is true
and i think we all need to get onto
twitter immediately so our my twitter
account there will be a link in the
description
bring back stargate go over there join
let's start getting a bit of a campaign
going
i'll be linking that with stargate 365
days and any other stargate channel
that's willing to talk to me basically
please get over to the facebook channel
and we'll we'll be discussing these
things as well
share the video
make a comment
let's make as much noise as we can let's
make it very clear to amazon what we
want and what we don't want from our tv
show and you know um okay they might own
the rights but this is for us all right
this is
and you know let's be a stargate fan
democracy a gators democracy and let's
make our voices heard from the people
that are above us that are going to make
this tv show
because for me
if they do a hard reboot and they do it
well
i'll be the first one to go fair enough
well done
but i don't want
15 years of stargate television
including sgu which i'm not a biggest
fan of
um to just be white from the slate you
know i don't want to clean slate it
might make it easier for the tv
executives and movie executives to have
a clean slate but it's not what we want
as far as i'm concerned what happened in
sg1 is canon
that is what makes most of the show up
you know the movie was great but most of
what i love about stargate is the tv
show
i don't want that wiped out from
existence i don't want them to pretend
like it didn't happen
and let's really start fighting now
because these decisions haven't been
made yet but they are going to be made
in the next six months so
now is the time to act
and let's hope that none of what i've
talked about in this
video ever comes to pass because we make
so much noise they realize it's a bad
idea
so if you are new to the channel please
like subscribe hit that bell
notification it really helps me out and
um you can join the channel all of my
videos go on at least 24 hours earlier
for members and you know
a steady stream of income helps me make
more
content so
um
thanks very much guys please stay safe
and i will see you next time
you